[Musique]
attendez avant de passer sous ses
fameuses lampes rouges
j'aimerais vous parler de ma boule à z
c'est à cause de vous c'est bon c'est
entièrement à cause de vous aider donc
vous avez faisiez-vous j'ai tenus par
roger tout perdu je l'aimais plus de
blond et je n'ai plus de couvertures
pour la calvitie fait chier quoi ça
gagne du terrain
bon trêve de plaisanterie il est temps
de passer à des histoires que vous avez
aujourd'hui deux autres histoires
trouver sur les 100 m alors je sais que
vous êtes beaucoup à m'envoyer pas mal
de liens de ce raid qui se passe sur
twitter
le problème c'est que vous êtes beaucoup
à m'envoyer les mêmes ce raid pour la
raison simple et évidente qu'en fait ils
ont déjà énormément tourner donc du coup
je vais pas faire une vidéo dessus alors
qu'ils ont déjà tourné vous les avez
déjà lui même si vous aimez bien
commencé moi qui a raconté quand vous
n'avez pas à lire quand vous avez des
petites images d'illustration mais voilà
je préfère vous raconter des histoires
qui sont un peu secrète qui datent
parfois même de plusieurs années comme
l'une de celles que je raconte
aujourd'hui mais moi vous découvrez une
histoire vous êtes dedans et vous
écoutez pas juste un mec raconter
l'histoire vous avez déjà lu voilà c'est
un peu chiant ça quand même on est
d'accord alors aujourd'hui on est sur
deux histoires et pas trois mais ces
deux histoires plutôt longue qui
utilisent la même mécanique j'espère que
vous allez papa c'est là la soirée seul
j'espère vous avez des voisins autour de
chez vous j'espère que vous regardez pas
ça en mettant deux autres campagnes
auquel cas ça va être compliqué pour
vous aujourd'hui bref comment sont pour
la première histoire assez bas dans
celle de billy billy a emménagé a pas
très longtemps dans un quartier en
construction en australie quartier en
construction ça veut dire qu'il ya des
maisons qu'on finit d'être construite
mais d'autres qui sont encore en
construction mais parfois vous savez les
chantiers sont en pause et c'est donc
bref y'a des quartiers dans lesquels
pendant plusieurs années il ya très peu
de maisons en fait par rapport à la
taille du quartier wihr eu le temps de
se balader pendant des semaines dans son
quartier avec son chien
il a un chien qui a son importance dans
cette histoire comme à chaque fois à
part sa maison à lui à une seule vraie
maison qu'à l'air d'être en fin de
construction et d'après ce qu'il a pu
comprendre billy personne n'y habite qu
il est vraiment tout seul petit détail à
quelques centaines de mètres de la
maison de billy se trouvent des champs
avec une grande colline et les chants et
7 collines appartiennent à l'état voilà
donc personne n'est autorisé à
construire ici et le terrain et même des
limites et par de grandes barrières qui
font tout le tour en gros personne a le
droit d'aller là bref le contexte est
posée maintenant passons aux choses
bizarres qui commence deux mois après le
bélier emménagé il se réveille un matin
sous le son d'un
violon il n'y a pas spécialement prêter
attention au début parce qu'il s'est dit
tout simplement que ça y est ils avaient
enfin des voisins et que souvenez vous
la maison en construction en face de
chez lui avait peut-être enfin reçu ses
habitants donc billy quasiment sûr de
lui au tchèque si c'est le cas et en
poussant le rideau qu'est ce qu'ils
voient personne dans la maison d'en face
ça ne venait pas du tout de là où il y
avait de grandes chances qu'il y ait des
gens sauf que je vous le rappelle tout
le reste c'est des terrains avec que
dalle dessus donc il est comme un comble
à partir de là tous les deux jours il se
passe la même chose c'est-à-dire le
ministre abeilles à cause du bruit d'un
violon et au bout de 45 50 secondes
leçons de violon disparaît et puis se
rendort bon déjà je sais pas comment il
a fait pour pas être stressé par ça va
vraiment tu te réveilles à cause du
bruit d'un violon ça arrive une fois la
deuxième fois tu te plaît avec une hache
dans les mains et tueur la chose
suivante qui joue du violon bon
rassurez-vous malgré tout au bout de
plusieurs jours un matin billy se révèle
une énième fois ce bruit du violon et il
se dit bon asie peut-être je vais tuer
quand même par la fenêtre voir si je
vois quelque chose et il voit en haut de
la fameuse colline dont je vous ai parlé
entouré par des chants une silhouette de
quelqu'un avec un violon on est le matin
très tôt le soleil en train de se lever
donc ya pas une grosse luminosité
ambiante mais billy distingue c'est une
silhouette et surtout il arriva
distinguèrent détail important la
silhouette fait comme une sorte de valse
c'est à dire qu'elle tourne lentement en
cercle tout en jouant du violon
chacun ses activités ses passe-temps moi
je vais pas critiquer son believe a
ensuite quitté la personne des yeux pour
ramasser son petit journal du matin on
parle donc de 10 secondes mais pendant
qu'ils regardent plus la personne le
bruit de violon s'arrête d'accord en
toute logique notre ami relève la tête
pour vous regardez la silhouette qui l'a
vu au loin et effectivement la
silhouette ne joue plus violents de
densité est parfaitement immobile en
regardant dans la direction de bill les
deux restent comme ça pendant d'après
les propos de billy 30 secondes et puis
il décide de rentrer dans sa maison et
d'arrêter ce petit jeu de regards parce
que c'est quand même un peu critique
mais bon jusque là rien de grave rien de
bizarre comme j'ai dis chacun sait
qu'ici à des mecs qui veulent jouer du
violon en dansant au milieu de la nature
bomba ainsi soit-il tant qu'ils ne
révèlent pas à 7 heures du matin borden
sauf que après ce matin là il ya des
trucs plus creepy que ça qui commencent
à arriver autour de la maison de bélier
remarqué il ya des empreintes de pas sur
les propriétés environnantes mais c'est
pas ces empreintes de pas à lui et il
les a jamais vus avant bon ça reste
juste des empreintes de pas monde ici
tout comme billy suppose que ça venait
probablement de gens qui venaient d'un
autre quartier d'habitation un peu plus
billy pour x raisons mais aux trucs un
peu bizarres il a aussi entendu des
bruits de pas autour de chez lui comme
si quelqu'un se balader dans sa rue
alors qui a rien dans sa rue je rappelle
tout en construction au travail il a
aussi reçu des appels ou quand il
décroche et la personne qui a appelé
raccrocher immédiatement enfin bref
c'est plein de petits éléments comme ça
mis bout à bout qui sont un peu chelou
baby lise dit ça reste des empreintes de
pas il ya des chantiers un peu par ici
bon voila il trouve en tout cas une
explication rationnelle à tout ce qu'ils
voient et c'est le réflexe humain le
réflexe que tu as raison d'avoir dans
99% des cas mais quand tu es dans un
pour cent des cas comme billy il fallait
rester en alerte et rester vigilant dans
sa maison bélisle à un bureau dans
lequel il passe pas mal de temps puisque
apparemment c'est un gros gamer et passe
beaucoup de temps sur les jeux vidéos
bref ce soir là il est en train de jouer
il décide d'aller prendre à boire dans
son frigo situation classique et en
revenant vers son bureau et voix par la
fenêtre de toutes petites lumières et
comprend pas ce que c'est donc il se
rapproche de la vitre il colle quasiment
sonné contre la vitre pour fixer ses
deux petites lumières sans comprendre ce
que c'est lorsqu'il réalise que c'est
pas des lumières
il ya des yeux qui sont là à un mètre de
billy en train de le fixer à travers sa
fenêtre et notre ami a tellement eu peur
mais c'est la première fois que ça
arrive dans un thread je crois que je
raconte en vidéo que ses muscles ont
lâché en fait il est tombé par terre
après avoir réalisé qu'il y avait un
visage quelqu'un qu'il observait la
l'autre côté de ça vite fait pareil et
devinez quoi une fois à terre billets en
temps quelqu'un qui commence à jouer du
violon
c'est le fameux [ __ ] de joueur de
violon qui est là à un mètre de lui
qu'il a observées et qui s'est mis à
jouer du violon après l'avoir vu se chie
dessus pendant que le mec se met à jouer
de plus en plus vite le morceau est de
plus en plus fort il ya le chien de
billy souvenez-vous qui comprend qu'ils
aient un truc pas normal qui se passe et
qui se met à aboyer le bruit de violon
s'arrête aussi tôt
eh ben ils y voient à travers sa fenêtre
la silhouette se déplaçait en direction
de sa course en direction de là où il ya
son chien vit vie reprend le contrôle de
son corps parce qu'il a peur pour son
chien il est inquiet il n'a pas envie
qu'il arrive un truc à son cher billy
sort donc de sa maison pour aller au
côté de son chien et il essaie de le
faire rentrer dans la maison mais le
chien ne bouge pas et croyez-moi quand
un chien qu'à la corpulence d'un
labrador ne veut pas bouger
bah tu ne peux pas le bouger c'est
simple ils restent là cette scène elle
dure plusieurs dizaines de secondes
d'un côté la silhouette dans l'obscurité
quelque part devant de l'autre côté
billy derrière son chien avec ce dernier
qui arrêtent pas d'aboyer et finit alors
par entendre la silhouette s'éloigner
des bruits de pas qui partent comme ça
au loin mais des bruits de pas à pas en
rythme comme caen
tu marches des bruits de pas qui ont
plutôt le rythme d'une sorte de danse
une sorte de valse exactement comme il
l'avait vu faire en de la colline son
chien alors arrêtez d'aboyer et ils sont
rentrés dans la maison et à partir de ce
jour billy n'a plus jamais entendu
parler de cette silhouette n'a plus
jamais entendu un bruit de violon n'a
plus jamais eu quoi que ce soit bizarre
qui lui est arrivé dans les deux années
qui ont suivi ces incidents il ya des
gens qui ont commencé à emménager
enfin dans le quartier de billy il
explique qu'il a à raconter ce qui lui
était arrivé à tout le quartier et que
personne n'a jamais entendu un bruit de
viol on n'a jamais vu quelqu'un de
suspects dans le quartier donc voilà ça
reste une histoire que lui seul a vécu
et aura vécu et vous entendez vous
régulièrement un bruit de viol où vous
devriez peut-être vous inquiéter bon
j'espère que cette histoire vous a plu
la deuxième est tout aussi bas dans tes
en fait c'est un peu la même mécanique
et j'ai été un peu sensibles à ces
mécaniques l'adula personnes est la
seule à vivre le truc relou est horrible
et effrayant et du coup les gens à qui
elle en parle si elles osent en parler
peuvent douter de ce qu'elle dit en fait
puisqu'elle est la seule à l'avoir vécu
bref la deuxième histoire c'est celle de
sabrina sabrina elle est vendeuse dans
un magasin de vêtements de grande
renommée
elle explique qu'elle n'a pas le droit
de par son contrat de dire le nom et
elle y travaille dans la partie stock
livraisons en gros c'est l'arrière
boutique 1 c'est là où tu reçois les
vêtements avant de les mettre en rayon
donc tu versa dans des colis et puis tu
comptes le stock du compte le nombre de
produits etc
on est quelques semaines avant noël et
sabrina demande à ses supérieurs si elle
peut faire quelques heures sup pour
avoir plus d'argent pour offrir de plus
beau cadeau de noël à ses proches n'est
ce pas une personne fantastique
sabrina étang en temps partiel sont
responsables ils proposent plutôt que de
la faire venir à des jours où elle ne
travaille pas habituellement et bien
tout simplement de la faire travailler
plus longtemps les jours où elle vient
travailler c'est à dire que de finir à
midi elle finira à 19h soit responsable
explique même que comme elle a 3 ans
d'ancienneté et lui fait confiance et il
est sûr qu'elle assurera la bonne
fermeture du magasin
le soir c'est maintenant que l'histoire
commence il est 20h tous ses collègues
ont terminé le travail
ils partent tous de la boutique et du
coup sabrina ferme derrière eux le
devant de la boutique pour que plus
personne du grand public ne puisse
rentrer et faire des achats
la musique du magasin éteinte la plupart
des lumières aussi et sabrina elle est
dans la réserve
au deuxième étage elle en train de
mettre des cintres en place pour le
lendemain réceptionner des colis et
mettre les fringues directement sur les
cintres parce que comme celle approche
de noël
eh ben ils reçoivent beaucoup beaucoup
de stock dans cette période là les
magasins donc elle prépare tout ça c'est
quelqu'un qui travaille bien pendant
calmer les cintres elle lève la tête
puis elle voit qu'il ya une peluche qui
est posée entre deux bouts mois devant
elle
bon pour le moment on s'en bat les
couilles de ce détail mais il va servir
plus tard quelque chose elle à brancher
son ipod à une paire d'enceintes qui est
dans la réserve parce que ben vous
connaissez toujours plus cool de tafer
en musique mais malgré la musique elle
entend un bruit
bon ça peut être mille choses sauf que
ce bruit c'est les stores mécaniques de
la zone de chargement qui sont en train
de s'ouvrir
elle panique pas pour le moment et elle
descend les escaliers pour avoir un
visuel sur la zone de chargement
inférieur sachant que ces [ __ ] de
stores mécaniques le seul moyen de les
ouvrir c'est un bouton qui se trouve à
l'intérieur on peut pas les ouvrir de
l'extérieur et sur le chemin petite
précision il ya plein de lumière à
détecteur de mouvements quand tu passes
devant le détecteur de mouvement en
tentant une sorte de clip qui vient de
la lumière avant qu'elle s'allume elle
arrive enfin dans la zone de chargement
inférieure et la personne le store
métallique est complètement fermée et
ajuste sabrina sol qui se dit ok tout va
bien sauf que avant d'aller voir ce qui
se passait à la zone inférieure elle
avait coupé la musique de son ipod est
là elle réalise que la musique et
relaxant qu'elle ait jamais toucher de
nouveau à son ipod
des bugs ça arrive vous admettrez que la
situation est un peu bas dans ce bref
sabrina reprend l'escalier elle remonte
au deuxième étage du coup pour continuer
son travail
hélas le coup de grâce elle lève la tête
et elle voit que la fameuse peluche a
disparu à partir de ce moment elle a
plus de doute elle sait qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui est là elle ne sait pas
qui elle ne connais pas ses intentions
mais elle sait qu'elle n'est pas seule
sabrina part alors en courant et se
réfugier dans les toilettes pour femmes
non loin de là et plus particulièrement
dans l'une des quatre cabines que
contiennent les toilettes pour femmes
à partir de là sabrina considère qu'il
ya plus de danger imminent qu'elle est
seule dans cette pièce est elle se met
alors à réfléchir pour trouver une
solution en fait ce qui lui arrive elle
essuie son front avec son avant bras
gauche et en tournant la tête elle a vu
un visage par terre
revenir en direction de la cabine qui
est à côté de la sienne la personne qui
est dans magasin est rentré dans les
toilettes pour femmes et cette personne
vient de checker dans la cabine à côté
de la sienne et a donc vu ou et et
sabrina le visage qu'elle a vue
correspond à celui d'une personne
apparemment vieil hôtel gris et avec
beaucoup de rides qui aurait les dents
noires et les lèvres légèrement abîmée
puis ce qu'elle saignait comme si la
personne s'était automutilée sachant que
l'intrus se trouve dans la cabine à côté
de la sienne
elle lui hurle d'aller se faire [ __ ]
tout en mettant des gros chassé dans la
porte de sa cabine mutuelle prend une
grande respiration et elle décide de
sortir de la cabine et de tracer de
l'autre côté du magasin
heureusement pour elle rien ni personne
ne s'est interposé dans sa charge vers
la sortie du magasin elle sent alors
l'accueil du magasin
être déverrouillé la porte et elle
explique que c'était pas une tâche
facile vu qu'elle était dans un état de
panique totale et que ses mains
tremblent et bouc et une fois sorti du
magasin elle se dirige vers la clé qui
permet vous savez de faire descendre le
rideau métallique du magasin de suspense
dure un peu et savannah décide de
regarder par dessus le rideau métallique
au moment où ils arrivent très proche du
sol et elle revoit une nouvelle fois
cette personne debout au milieu du
magasin avec cette fois la peluche dans
la main servez na se barre en courant
dans la rue et une fois sur la rue
principale
elle prend son portable pas son ipod qui
était toujours dans le magasin mais son
portable elle appelle la police pour
leur dire qu'elle pense que quelqu'un
est entré par effraction dans son
magasin et qui s'y trouvent encore et
malheureusement il ne trouve personne
et le lendemain matin sabrina retourne
au taf il ya la police ils sont
responsables de magasin mais il n'y a
pas de news de cet intrus voilà on a pas
news on sait pas qui c'était pourquoi il
était là sabrina va donc dans le stock
pour récupérer son ipod qu'elle n'avait
pas pris en partant du magasin la veille
et elle voit que la fameuse peluches et
d'un retour entre les deux morceaux de
bois du stock et depuis ce jour comme
pour notre ami billy elle a plus jamais
eu aucune news de cette personne c'était
un one shot c'est tombé sur elle elle a
eu zéro chatel s'en est jamais vraiment
complètement remis elle reste un peu
effrayé maintenant le soir quand elle se
retrouve seule dans le magasin où quoi
et surtout elle se pose la fameuse
question [ __ ] mais c'était qui est
qu'est ce qu'ils voulaient en fait et ce
qu'ils venaient pour voler des vêtements
et ce qu'ils venaient juste pour
retrouver un endroit où passer la nuit
qui était cette personne en fait voilà
c'était notre histoire du jour j'espère
qu'elle vous ont plu elle était très
longue mais très sympa je pense je me
dirige est plutôt maintenant vers des
histoires un peu plus longue et un peu
plus complète que des histoires très
courte parce que ben j'ai besoin de ça
pour être dedans moi et pour que ça ne
fasse quelque chose sinon c'est pas
assez contextualiser donc je n'arrive
pas trop à me mettre à la place de la
personne et donc j'ai pas trop peur bref
je ne serai jamais vendeur dans un
magasin en tout cas je serai pas de
fermeture si youtube se termine je ferai
pas les fermetures et si vous emménagez
quelque part fait en sorte que tout soit
bien construit qui est des voisins dans
le quartier 1 c'est plus agréable
je suis chaud pour que l'espace
commentaires de cette vidéo de ce serait
de la ce soit des gens qui racontent un
peu leur expérience du genre genre si
vous étiez seul à la maison et qui s'est
passé quelque chose ou alors seul sur
votre le travail qui s'est passé quelque
chose sûre c'est assez intéressant moi
je suis très sensible à cette mécanique
elle me fait vraiment du mal je vous dis
à bientôt rendant une prochaine vidéo
[Musique]